welcome back to our series about
bigquery cost optimization where today
we'll be focusing on how you can
optimize your queries specifically your
select queries for both cost and
performance
as a reminder bigquery is a fully
separated storage and compute Data
Warehouse in lake house which means that
you only pay for the storage as you need
it and you only pay for the compute as
you're analyzing data
the art of query optimization considers
both how you can optimize using storage
and compute to derive the best query
performance and query costs as a result
of different options you may take
so what can you do to actually optimize
your different select query performance
first let's think about how you can
optimize different parts of a query
because we'll take different methods
depending on the type of performance
that we need to optimize for and cost
optimize for
first is the i o or think of this as
things like the scans and the shuffles
that happen in our data this refers to
the amount of data that we pass around
either at the first scan is a part of
the scan or a subsequent steps as a part
of the shuffle
next we need to consider how our data is
joined at specific stages and aggregated
as a part of a stage or subsequent
stations this is how we can change our
groupings for how much how many bytes do
we pass through and how much CPU work
did this consume
last is how we can actually take this
and then change our materialization or
how much data we output as a result of
our queries
by reducing this we can improve our
query performance because there's less
data to actually write out to both
storage and to a result pan
so let's start optimizing
the first and most common optimization
for end user queries is changing the
default user Behavior so we don't run
select star across the table
because bigquery storage is columnar It
is Well optimized for running Aggregates
but not returning large amounts of data
across rows arbitrarily
it's a good idea when running a query to
only select the columns that you need or
use select start accept which is a
unique feature in bigquery to exclude
the columns which you know you don't
need this improves performance by
reducing the number of bytes scanned at
the outside and then also reduces the
bytes that are past the subsequent
stages
this principle of scan reduction also
applies to filter statements or where
Clauses in your queries generally the
sooner you can filter data the better
and the more you can filter at the start
the less data will be required at the
end
next let's look at how table designs can
impact our query costs and performance
we just discovered covered how we can
use common performance optimization by
reducing the bytes scanned as a part of
our query syntax
partitioning in clustering tables
that are used by Common attributes is
another way to help continue to reduce
the byte scanned and sometimes improve
performance of other things like joins
you can use the recommender here which
runs in our background of bigquery to
propose table design options based on
the queries that you run to help both
improve performance and the resulting
costs of both the table and your query
reducing compute work is important to
improving the cost and performance of
bigquery
one of the most common drivers of high
compute is the use of functions like
order by or rank where data must be
sorted before it is outputted
it's best to do these at the very end of
a query as these operations typically
have to run on a small subset of data
and it typically can get pegged to a
small set of slots to actually do the
work
you can use limits also on these to help
reduce the amount of data that actually
is returned so once the limit is reached
the query can stop Computing which
improves the performance of the query
and how many slots you use at the end
last it's important to consider how skew
may impact your data SKU can be a
difficult concept at times to understand
but essentially this is how are we
getting things into equal components to
run across a distributed system
eliminating or reducing skew in your
queries can sometimes mean changing data
filters or redesigning how the data is
loaded into tables and stored so it is
evenly distributed which means that many
slots can work in parallel in order to
accomplish the common output of getting
your query done as fast as possible and
at the lowest costs
we hope you found these tips and tricks
useful for optimizing your query costs
and performance
querying